I went
on a Internet shopping spree
to find the weirdest
ping pong items
possible
Today you get to test them out
Are you ready?
We are ready
Excited about this
Okay, let’s get the first item
What?
You gotta have it here
You gotta hit the ball
Oh, wait a second
No, no!
Not that ball!
You play like this
Yeah!
That’s underwhelming, Otto
And I broke it
Remember the London video?
There was the guy who said:
Keep an eye on the ball
Keep eye on the ball!
This is the toy for that guy!
It’s a practice tool
Keep eye on the ball!
Yeah!
This is the actual use
This is my theory
So, you are also guessing?
You neither have no idea?
I have no idea
None of these things
came with instructions
You can get a rally going
Otto hits up
Emil hits down
But it doesn’t like
improve you at all
Does the “eye watching?”
It does!
Oh, now we found the touch
It’s a jackpot machine
It’s a device
for a ping pong doctor
I can hear his thoughts
*mumbling*
He is telling me to hit
only backhand from now on
Let’s rate it
I’ll give it one star out of five
Don’t get this one
Unless you really know
how to use it
because we probably didn’t
For the next item
We will build you
a small obstacle course
Three, two, one
It’s a ball picker
This could be the first
truly useful item
So it’s human versus machine
Ready
Set
Go!
Otto is in the lead
Otto, you lost a ball
Otto missed a ball
And we are done
It’s not the sturdiest
And it’s very shaky
This came loose
Two out of five stars
Only two stars?
Well, it lost to the hand
Do you have your eyes closed?
Close your noses
Close your ears
Listen to the sounds and try
to figure out what’s going on
Peeling something off
You can open your eyes
This is like the first
Michael O’Connor painting
Yeah, I’m revealing
a portrait of myself
It’s the rubber wall?
Woooahh!
It has sticky rubbers
Feels like a good built
Oh!
It works!
Not bad
This item is useful
Yeah!
It returned even that...
Yes!
C’mon!
Otto, you’re took good at blocking
Yeah, let’s rate it
Three and a half
I’d probably give it four stars
Solid item
Challenge for this board
is to give yourself
an around the net spot
off the board
and hit it around the net
Let’s try it out
Hit the ball
a bit more from the middle
Emil is engineering
Yes!
Otto, what racket are you using?
That’s an incredible one!
Boom!
Sensei racket:
Perfect for around the nets
How many stars?
It’s a battle
Between us?
Between you two
The item is...
A smoothie machine
What’s the challenge, Miikka?
The robot is spitting the balls
First one to be able to
return the ball
back into the track wins
Aaaaa!
Nice challenge
Ooh!
That was close
Nice try!
Ooh!
Equaliser
Almost got it
What’s the rating
for the little ball monster?
It’s a simple robot
but it’s useful
My personal favorite part of this
is twirly whirly
I would give it three out of five
I would also!
Before we reveal the next item
we have a challenge for you guys
We are launching a new product
on Pongfinity.store
And you get to choose
what it is!
It’s two items
This is obviously
the stance
This is the item
that we are looking for
Oh, it’s not
There’s a specific ball for that
But should it be on the ground?
This item was a stupid idea
Don’t break it
before the challenge begins, Emil
Okay, sorry
The challenge is to create
a twenty second
table tennis show
using these however you want
You wanna take some notes?
I might do!
Welcome to this
magical table tennis show
Hosted by Duo Pong
Okay, please!
Music, please!
Oho!
Okay!
I’m not sure
what I think about this part but
20 seconds is up!
Twenty seconds is up!
It started off promising
Due to the traumatizing ending
I’m gonna have to
give this performance
a solid four
Four out of four
Nice!
It was actually four out of twenty
On to the next
What will it be?
This goes
maybe on the table
This goes here
Aha!
This is good!
The guys are enjoying it
Okay, tell us the challenge!
The next challenge is:
a target shot
And you have to shoot the ball
to make it to spin
Aaa!
I think it’s gonna spin like
three seconds
three seconds?
It has to hit like
the top of the ball
Ooh!
It spun!
One second?
Ooh!
Oh, wow!
That is very impressive!
That’s like five seconds!
Should we try
Does this thing actually work
If Lassi
you practice some shots on this
and then see if it affects
your forehand loop
Show your normal forehand loops
Uuh!
Argh!
Hey!
Does it feel like
you are getting better?
Yes, let’s do it!
Okay!
Wow!
That was crazy!
But then you need
to continue from that
You can give the rating for this
this item
Last one
Five stars
It actually works
I’ve never seen anything like it
This is really good practice
for beginners
Is this our new product?
Let us know in the comments
Next item also belongs
to the category:
Try and figure out
what on earth it is?
This is the thing
I think they’re getting
a bit distracted from
the actual task here
It has to be with the spin
Like that
Do you think
they are going to figure it out?
No chance!
Because the actual use
makes zero sense whatsoever
I don’t think it’s the spin
because that makes sense
It’s a tool for
cleaning the table
Hey, I know!
When you glue the rubber
If you wanna really uneven glue
Let me show you the correct answer
Give me a second
I’ve got to get it set up
No!
It’s to get the hip
more into the forehand technique
Is that a joke?
No, no!
This is seriously
what it said on the website!
To stabilize the core!
It’s not made for all sizes
Wow!
It’s working!
Great!
How would you rate it?
Three for massage
Zero for elbow technique
You could also use
just any stick
So it averages on about two stars
What has Miikka bought
from the Internet?
It can’t be another robot?
Your guess is...
Correct!
Oh, yes!
It gives serves
Max speed
I have a better challenge for this
You have to come up with a trick shot
The net on the table
This challenge might be too easy
I think so too
It’s time
for the handsome tiger
This one left at least
me speechless
It must be used like this
Can’t really use spin
Yeah!
Have to play without spin
I mean you can play with it
You are quite good at it
I think this is
the correct use of the handsome tiger
It makes a nice song too
Yeah?
I might not come with the purchase
If the payment is enough big!
We have to compare it
With the rubber wall
I give this
Two stars
Simply because it doesn’t
allow you to make spins
It’s like a chair without legs
And it broke
the first time we tried it
Yeah!